The End No retreat and no surrender, stillness into deutsche Bahn, no retreat, here we come, no surrender together, stillness coming for you into deutsche Bahn, Ru, vielen Dank.
Und das ist der Moment, wo du noch meinen Namen sagen musst, sonst weiss niemand, wie ich bin.
Warum kann man so gut schreien im Flüstern eigentlich?
Es ist besser, man kann besser schreien, als man im Flüstern.
Aber warum ist das überhaupt, wie geht das überhaupt? In welchen Situationen muss man schreien, während man flüstert? Gibt's ja nicht. Gibt's ja nicht. Naja, du musst schon manchmal laut flüstern. Also wirklich, gerade so Thema Ruheabteil, das Dabst du noch mal aufmacht, so ... Entschuldigung, Sie sitzen hier im Ruheabteil, das ist nicht schon klar! Naja, gut, da musst du schon ran. Oder so ein passiv-aggressives Pärchen so. Du hast doch gerade schon gegessen. Ja. Du hast doch gerade schon gegessen. Und wenn er wütend ist, dann betont man die einzelnen Silben auch noch etwas deutlicher. Wir haben gerade gesagt, dass wir ein bisschen bräuchten, ein bisschen in die Gütter treten müssen, bei den ganzen Kalorien, die du reinpfeffest. Sehr ungesundes Pärchen miteinander. Aber vielen Dank an Dabsi, dass er die Akte Ruheabteil nochmal aufmacht. Ich habe viel Solidarität bekommen, vielen, vielen Dank. Meine Idee war, endlich den schlafenden Riesen Deutsche Bahn zu wecken mit einer Stickerkampagne, das historisch erfolgreichste Mittel, um politischen Erfolg zu erzielen, eine Stickerkampagne. Klar. Und ich habe viel Solidarität bekommen, viel Unterstützung, allerdings auch Warnungen vor Konsequenzen.
Von wem?
Ich mag keine Konsequenzen und viele haben mich darauf hingewiesen, die namenlos bleiben sollen.
Es sind unsere Untergrundkämpfer an vorderster Front.
Die meinten, pass auf, Hausverbot könnte eine Folge sein, deutsche Verbarung.
Das sind unsere Untergrundkämpfer, die sowas dann sagen.
Ich meine, ich bin auf die Deutsche Bahn angewiesen, ich bin Pendler, ich bin einer der Gruppen, die am härtesten getroffen werden könnten von einem Hausverbot. Aber auch am härtesten getroffen werden, wenn bei Ruhestürungen im Ruheabteil. Völlig richtig. Mein Ziel ist es ja, du kannst Leute, die einfach unrücksichtsvoll sind, nicht ändern. Wenn dir einfach egal ist, was die anderen Leuten antun, hast du verloren. aber man kann vielleicht helfen, dass Leute überhaupt wissen, dass sie im Ruhrabteil sind, wissen viele nämlich nicht. Die telefonieren dann und dann sagen sie, was im Ruhrabteil wusste ich gar nicht. So, und deswegen die Stickerkampagne. Ich habe mich jetzt dazu entschieden, das eher zu einer Schläferkampagne zu machen. Also der Samen wurde gesetzt in den Köpfen der Hörer und ich habe Hypnose-Techniken angewendet, damit im richtigen Moment, wenn tatsächlich Du meinst letzte Woche bei der Podcastaufzeichnung, wo ich kurz unmächtig geworden bin und auf den Tisch gefallen bin. Das tut mir wirklich leid. Ich mache das nie wieder. Das war nicht gegen dich gerichtet, aber anscheinend bist du mental so schwächlich, dass du selbst wenn andere im Nebenraum hypnotisiert werden, du auch einfach zum Hühnchen wirst und nicht mehr rauskommst. Ja. neulich gedacht, wenn einem Leute auf der Strasse entgegenkommen. Du sagst jetzt, ich bin schwächlich. Und ich bin auch tendenziell auf der Strasse, wenn man einen kurzen, kleinen, schmalen Bürgersteig hat, immer der, der eher zur Seite geht. Ich will nicht der sein, der, wenn man so breitschulterigen Leuten entgegenkommt, die schon diesen fiesen Blick haben, diesen fiesen, ich werde dich mit meiner Schulter unsammt zur Seite stoßen, wenn du deine Bahn einhältst, dem will ich aus dem Weg gehen. Und Leute wie du sagen dann immer, das ist schwächlich, das ist schwächliches Verhalten. Ist es nicht das viel cleverere Verhalten? Bei demjenigen gehört ja die Strasse nicht, sondern und ich will ja aber nur, ich will jetzt aber auch nicht, ich fühle mich nicht schwächer in der Position, wenn ich zur Seite gehe, weil ich ja trotzdem, ich habe ja quasi auf das Pferd gesetzt, was in the long run, weißt du, weil es geht ja darum, ich möchte nicht verprügelt werden. Ja, nicht nochmal. Nicht nochmal, das brauche ich nicht jeden Tag und deswegen habe ich doch den besseren Tag als der, der vielleicht an fünf Leute anstößt und dann auch ab und zu unangenehm wird, weil du hast ja immer einen Adrenalinschub, kannst du mir nicht erzählen, wenn du Herzklopfen, Schweißklopfen, wenn dir jemand entgegenkommt.
Ich stimme dir hundertprozentig zu, ich mache da einfach ein Tauschgeschäft, nämlich ich gehe einen Schritt zur Seite.
Für deine Gesundheit.
Dafür bin ich derjenige, der den anderen unangenehm pedantisch darauf hinweist, dass ich jetzt aus dem Weg gehen musste.
Also mein Deal ist, ich gehe einen Schritt aus dem Weg, dafür ein ... Wirklich? Ja, sowas. Ein sassy Blick. Ein mütender Blick, ja, ein Schnipp, ein Kopfschlag, so einfach, damit der andere möglichst weiss, dass er gerade dafür gesorgt hat, dass ich mir die extra Mühe machen muss, aus dem Weg zu gehen. Also das ist mein Trade-off. Ich gehe aus dem Weg, ich mache mir die extra Mühe, dafür darf ich pedantisch unangenehm sein und ein und dann drücke ich mich manchmal so unnötig, so gegen die Wand, so wirklich und mache mich dreckig und drücke mich in den Dreck. Was gar nicht nötig ist, Bürgersteig ist zehn Meter breit. Ich haue einfach noch so eine Magazine aus dem Regal von so einem Strassenmagazin laden und drück da alles rum. Entschuldigung, jetzt muss ich es kaufen. Und wirklich einfach viel zu grosses Theater. Du sagst, Entschuldigung, jetzt muss ich es kaufen. Ja, damit die Person sich möglichst schlecht fühlt. Das ist mein Trade-off. Ich springe sehr immer gross aus dem Weg. Sehr exaltiert springe ich aus dem Weg. So, ich sehe ja schon, dass es mir entgegenkommt. Und dann gehe ich viel zu spät, mache ich dann so einen sprunghaften, so einen Satz, so einen James-Bond-artigen, ich muss nur unter das Tor, was langsam zugeht, springen, so einen Satz zur Seite und sage, ach Gott, Leute. Ich habe mir auch überlegt, ob es sich lohnen würde, sich einen Kinderwagen zu besorgen. Also nicht mehr normalerweise den Rucksack, ich habe den Rucksack immer dabei. Und ob ich nicht umsteigen soll auf dem Kinderwagen, wo ich einfach meine Sachen dabei habe. Weil ein Kinderwagen ist einfach so der Panzer der Grossstadt. Niemand geht in deinen Weg, niemand. Du ballerst überall durch, jeder, selbst der härteste Typ, springt aus dem Weg, du ballerst einfach durch, du walzt alles nieder. Volvo, ich walze alles nieder. Deswegen auch diese alte Wild-West-Züge vorne, die sie diesen Flug haben, wo die dann so alte Wüstenreste noch wegflügen. Das sollte man vorne so panzermäßig an so Kinderwagen, so Tarnkappen-Kinderwagen. Ohnehin so ein Mad Max-Kinderwagen einfach mit so brennenden, rotierenden Klingen. Babys sind eh wie Warlords. Wenn ihr Mad Max Fury World gesehen habt, ob das jetzt so ein dicker, nackter, sonnengebrannter Typ sitzt, so ein Warlord oder so ein Baby, was alle einfach todisch starrt, ist es auch im Prinzip das gleiche. Ja, stimmt schon. Wenn du da so manchmal so ein Kind siehst mit einem Bein über dem Geländer von so einem Kinderwagen in der rechten Hand so ein Stück Brezel wie so eine Zigarre angesabbert und einfach mit so einem Die-Stadt-gehört-mir-Blick. Das habe ich mir eigentlich überlegt, aber ich gebe dir völlig recht, man sollte zur Seite gehen. Ja, ich war neulich, wusste ich nicht, wie ich reagieren sollte, weil ich war auf dem Fahrradweg und ich bin schon in diesem, ich reg mich gleich auf, wenn mir jemand den Weg schneidet oder so, ich habe schon, also auch weil es mir Spaß macht, das ist so mein, du hast die Wutarmbrust schon gespannt und den Finger auf dem Abzug. Das ist so mein Boxsack, weißt du, wo man dann so, wenn man Leute sieht in so Filmmontagen, die es dann so Wut wegtrinken oder gegen den Boxsack hauen oder sowas. Bei mir ist es die Vennloher Strasse in Ehrenfeld, wo man einfach dann mit dem Fahrrad langfährt und man kann sich so schön aufregen. Es kommen immer Türen, es ist nie wirklich gefährlich, aber es kommen immer so Türen mal in den Weg, jemand, ein Autofahrer fährt zu weit drauf und meine Arme fliegen immer
in die Höhe.
Und oh, was ist denn hier los?
Und alle Leute sind ja...
Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, das geht jetzt nicht.
Handzeichen bitte!
Das geht jetzt ja nicht.
Und das ist das Coole, weil alle Leute sind ja auf deiner Seite als Fahrradfahrer.
Das heißt, ich war schon in diesem Aufregmodus und dann sah ich schon so ein Hindernis
kommen und ich habe schon gesagt, yes, here we go. Dafür haben wir geprobt, dann war es eine Rollstuhlfahrerin, die ist dann auf den Fahrradweg gefahren und meine Hand war halt schon an der Klingel, mein Mund war, die Armbrust war gespannt. An der Snoopy-Klingel. Die Snoopy-Klingel war schon durchgedrückt, bis ich dann sah als Rollstuhlfahrerin, in dem Moment klingel ich aber schon, und mein Mund war schon ausgeholt zum Was soll das denn? Und dann ist das so ausgefisselt, weil ich nicht wusste. Auf der anderen Seite, gut, als körperlich disabled person kannst du jetzt ja auch nicht einfach ... Also es war kein Grund dafür, gab's für sie.
Ne? Sie hätte ja einfach ...
Du musstest kurz deine schon bestehende Wut rechtfertigen.
Ja.
Und du hast einfach wild um dich gegriffen nach Argumenten.
Und meintest so, ja, aber nur weil ...
Über Leute.
Naja, aber also, und alle drehen sich so angewidert von dir weg
und lassen von dir ab und du stehst alleine da. Aber das ist jetzt, das weiß ich jetzt nicht. Also dann habe ich überlegt lange, weil natürlich sollte man das nicht versuchen zu argumentieren, dass man da jetzt irgendwie im Recht sich aufgeregt hat. Auf der anderen Seite kann sie ja nicht einfach auf den, also sie kann nicht machen, was sie will. Ein Rollstuhl ist ja nicht, wie du hast gesagt, Kinderwagen ist ein Freifahrtschein, sich im Straßenverkehr zu behandeln wie der größte Arsch. Ein Rollstuhl, ich weiß nicht, ich habe mich in so einer Larry-David-artigen Position wiedergefunden, wo ich dachte, nur weil sie jetzt im Rollstuhl sitzt, kann sie ja jetzt nicht einfach in die Strasse stechen und ich fall da drüber. Ja, ich würde ganz klassisch sagen, read the room, schau, wie die Passanten sich verhalten, erheb mal leicht die Stimme und guck, wie die umgestehenden Passanten reagieren. Ja, habe ich ja gemacht. Wenn die annicken und wirklich so ein anbeissendes Annicken geben, dann weiter rein, rein, rein, rein, rein und wenn die eher die kalte Schulter geben und vielleicht auch den Vogel, dann eher absagen. Das heißt, du handelst ausschließlich so, wie du das Gefühl hast, wie das Umfeld von dir verlangt, sich zu verheilen. Ja, absolut. Ich lasse mich treiben von der Gruppe der Masse, von meiner Masse auf jeden Fall. Also die Masse war deutlich gegen mich, deswegen habe ich dann ganz schnell gesagt. Ich reg mich hier nicht auf. Ja, aber vielen Dank nochmal an Dabsi für den Ruhrabteil-Intro. Es ist auf jeden Fall schön, diese Solidarität zu bekommen, aber es ist auch schwierig, weil mittlerweile habe ich das Gefühl, die Gegenfront rüstet auch auf. Also die Störer werden auch klüger. Ich war zum Beispiel in einem Abteil, also sechs Plätze mit zwei Störern. Erst kam ein Störer rein, dann kam noch eine Störerin dazu und das war natürlich Nitroglycerin zusammen und dann hieß es so, ah, auch in Heidelberg stud studierst du hier? Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Also viereinhalbstündige Diskussionen über Studium und Arbeit und was arbeitest du? Aber spannend, da will ich direkt alles drüber wissen. Nee, war mir völlig egal. Und kennst du noch den Club da? Ja, der hat jetzt wieder aufblabblab. Und dann aber hat der Störer gesagt, und dann saß ich letztens so im Zug völlig leer Und dann kommt da so ein klassischer Pedantentyp auf mich zu und meinte, ich sitze auf seinem reservierten Platz und scheucht mich weg, typisch deutsch. Und ich dachte mir, okay, ab jetzt kann ich nicht mehr sagen, Entschuldigung, ist Ihnen vielleicht aufgefallen, dass Sie im Ruheabteil sitzen, kann ich ab jetzt nicht mehr machen, weil er hat schon sein Schild hochgezogen, er hat schon den Konter bereit, ich könnte jetzt natürlich das wieder unterlaufen. Es wurde verbal aufgerüstet. Es wurde verbal aufgerüstet, er hat mir die Falle gestellt. Ich könnte jetzt vielleicht kommen mit, ja, ich weiß, das ist jetzt super deutsch und so, Entschuldigung, aber dann würde ich aber implizit beweisen, dass ich die ganze Zeit zugehört habe, was mich noch unsympathischer macht, wo er sagen kann, ja, Sie müssen ja nicht zuhören die ganze Zeit und so. Also ich hatte keine Chance mehr. Aber gab es keine Verbündeten? Nein, keine Verbündeten. Ich war zwei Störer zu einem vernünftigen, gutherzigen Mensch, sag ich es mal. Und ich hatte von meiner ersten Sekunde an verloren und das kam nach fünf Minuten. Und dann versuche ich manchmal, dann habe ich dem Gespräch schon ein bisschen zugehört, aber nur um rauszufinden, bis wohin sie fahren, damit ich eruieren kann, lohnt sich die Flucht noch oder fahren die Inno zwei Stationen und hast aber mehr über die Klubs in Heidelberg erfahren als über die nächsten Stoff. Leute, ich kenne mich aus, Leute, also falls ihr mal in Heidelberg feiern gehen wollt, ruf mich an, ich kenne mich aus. Die Top 20 Clubs in Heidelberg jetzt.
Auf Platz 20 natürlich Totoro. Klar, Totoro. Auf Platz 19 natürlich die Schmiesengasse. Das ist natürlich die beste. Achso, ich dachte, mehr japanische Kinderfilme, aber okay, es bleibt bei Totoro. Und ja, es war schlimm und da dachte ich mir, vor allem, ich dachte mir dann, wenn die aussteigen, hätte ich wirklich mal gerne nachgefragt, Entschuldigung, hätten sie sich anders verhalten, wenn hier ein grosser Sticker wäre mit Achtung, sie sind im Ruheabteil. Also, was mich ja oft interessiert ist, wissen diese Leute, dass sie im Ruheabteil sind oder ist es ihnen egal? Aber das gefällt mir, weil du dich nicht beschwert hast, Du warst nicht der Pedant, du wirst eher wie so ein Marktforscher.
Genau, ich bin eigentlich eher so der Undercover-Bahn-Mitarbeiter, der so, Entschuldigung, ich habe ein paar Fragen, vielleicht auch mal so ein paar Fragen vorstieben. Entschuldigung, ich habe ein paar Fragen zum Fahrkomfort, wie Ihnen die heutige Fahrt gefallen hat. Genau, was ist denn Ihr Sternzeichen? Erst mal so ein bisschen aus der Reserve. Was ist denn Ihre Adresse vielleicht? Und auf 0 bis 10, wie hat Ihnen die Fahrt gefallen? Nutzen Sie das Check-in-Feature und war Ihnen bewusst, dass Sie die gesamte fucking Fahrt im Ruhrabteil saßen? Oder haben Sie das nicht gesehen wegen dem Schild an der Tür? Nee, wir sind doch alle Freunde. Nee, aber ich hätte wirklich gerne eine Antwort. Aber ich habe es mir auch das nicht getraut. Aber es ist ein dezenter cooler Hinweis, dass die ganzen vier Stunden einfach sich gegen die Regeln widersetzt wurde. Es gefällt mir eigentlich ganz gut. Weil ich verstehe das schon so, man setzt sich ins Ruheabteil, denkt man will die Ruhe und dann trifft man aber die spannendste Person der Welt, einen anderen Studenten aus derselben Uni wie man selber, Wahnsinn! Und schon muss man die ganze Welt diskutieren. Also keine Chance, keine Chance für mich. Ich habe das Gefühl, es gibt irgendwo da draußen einen Podcast, der die Gegenseite unterstützt.
und denen sagt, hey, wenn ihr im Ruheabteil reden wollt,
dann sagt am besten, du kennst doch bestimmt diese typisch deutschen Pedanten,
die sich ständig beschweren und die Gegenseite kann nicht mehr machen.
Die wissen, wie sie uns am Kragen packen.
Währenddessen im anderen Podcast Nina und Frederik dann so und habe ich schon gesehen, da saß dieser typische Pedant da. Die erkennt man immer ganz gut an ihren dicken Noise-Canceling-Kopf. Genau, Noise-Canceling. Und die fahren ja viel. Da haben die schon so ihr Platz so eingerichtet, wie sie es immer tun. Netzteil schon direkt eingesteckt, Rucksack daneben, Alles da und sobald man mal ein Wort sagt, sofort so dieser Nackenhochreckenblick, so boah, nee. Und dann denkt man so, warum macht dann Kopfhörer lauter, das ist doch Neuskanzling-Kopfhörer, mach Neuskanzling an und so. Aber da kommt der Blick rüber und dieses leichte Augendrehen, das habe ich schon gar keinen Bock. Ja, und was man da gut machen kann, ist, du sagst einfach sowas wie, er findest eine Geschichte wie damals, als mir jemand den reservierten Platz weggenommen hat, ich hasse diese Pedanten typisch deutsch. Ja, weil dann kann er gar nichts machen. Er kann nichts machen, ist so klar. Schlacht matt einfach, du hast ihn umzingelt und dann bestenfalls noch ein Stück lauter reden, einfach um Dominanz zu zeigen. Währenddessen habe ich das Gefühl, dass die Gegenseite die Pedanten auch ein bisschen aufrüsten, weil ich habe ja schon ein paar Züge gesehen, wo so Sticker hingen, wo so ein großes Arschloch abgebildet war, wo drunterunter stand, Achtung, sitzen wir im Urur-Partei, vielen Dank, dass die mitmachen und so. Deswegen wäre mein Vorschlag, wir bringen Sticker raus und überkleben die. Das finde ich eine gute Idee. Und zwar mit dem typischen, dieses deutsche Bahnblau, diese Plastikoberfläche. Und kleben sowas drauf wie, nutzen Sie den Komfort-Check-In. Irgendwie sowas überkleben. Und einfach nur, dass es aussieht wie die Sitzrückseite und wir überkleben weil das ist einfacher als die anderen sticker runter zu knibbeln jeder der schon mal den sticker weggeknibbelt hat weiss es geht nicht weißt du was mir letztens passiert ist dann steige ich aus vor essen und dann fragt er mich entschuldigung war ihnen eigentlich bewusst dass sie die ganze zeit im wuppteil sitzen weil ich dachte mir fuck jetzt hat er michißt du, was ich gesagt habe? Den Satz und den, wirklich, hört gut zu, Leute,
schreibt euch auf, es ist der Satz, der dich aus jeder
Situation rausholt. Macht lauter kurz.
Und zwar habe ich gesagt, ja, ich will ja
meine Ruhe haben.
Oh mein Gott. Keine Chance.
Wie gehst du auf Strassen? Gehst du auch
breit herum? Ich gehe super breit.
Und jeder, der demgegenkommt, wird mit einer
Bilderkugel weggestoßen. Kein Zentimeter zur Seite. Nice, wir sind die coolsten. Wir sind die Störer. Die Störis. Nina und Frederik. Was für Arschlöcher. Hasse sie. Jeder hasse sie. Ganz doll. Und wegen Wörtern wie Arschlöcher sind wir PG-18, R-rated. Wir müssen das mal ausnutzen. Wir haben uns damals bei Erstellen des Podcasts überlegt, wollen wir ab 18 sein? Und wir haben gesagt, ja, und wir nutzen es nie. Das ist so, wie wenn man so einen Freifahrtschein hat, so die Lizenz zum Töten. Das ist wie, als würde man einen Rollstuhl haben und einfach auf dem Fahrradweg rumfahren oder nicht. Du bist diesen Kampf nicht gewünscht. Nee, ich möchte mich noch mal entschuldigen, weil es war auch nicht meine Intention, da jetzt rumzuhaten oder sowas. Ich habe nichts mehr. Aber ich wollte jetzt auch nicht. Ich war schon, wie gesagt, die Finger waren an der Klingel, der Mund war gespitzt, es ging nicht anders. Es tut mir leid, ich möchte mich entschuldigen für meinen rübhaftes Verhalten. Aber wir müssen mehr machen, ausser dem FSK 18 stimmt schon. Ich stelle mir auch so vor, so James Bond am letzten Tag vor der Rente. Du, sag mal, was mir aufgefallen ist. Ich habe ja damals, als ich angefangen habe bei MI6, als 007. Nee, nee, er hat angefangen als 002. Damals noch 002 und dann habe ich die Lizenz zum Töten bekommen. Also da meinte Pi damals noch zu mir. Ich habe Pi gehasst. Pi war, also das war einfach nicht mein Typ irgendwie. Zum Glück ist er irgendwann rausgeflogen. Puh, mochte ich. Und der meinte dann, du kannst töten, wen du willst. Jetzt ist mir gerade aufgefallen, morgen ist Rente. Zeig mal deine Lizenz zum Töten. Warst du da auch extra beim Fotografen? Ich habe, es ist einches Foto gemacht. Es ist ein altes Foto und meine Adresse ist falsch geschrieben. Es ist ein bisschen albern. Zeig mal. Oh nein, oh nein, nein, nein. Der wird ja nicht verlängert. Aber das ist fast ein bisschen sarkastisch, ne, auf der Lizenz zum Töten. Ach guck mal, das ist auch schön, ne, überall hinten dann diese dezenten Leichen im Hintergrund. Genau, und vor allem du hast so Wasserzeichen, du hast so einen abgeschnittenen Kopf und so eine Pistolenkugel, die sich so bewegt, je nachdem, wo ins Licht du das hältst. Aber dass du da jetzt diese langen, blonden Haare hast. Ja, es war eine, Zero Zero Two war einfach eine andere Zeit. Und das Sombrero musste sein. Der musste sein. Da lag beim Fotografen, lagen so verschiedene Props da. Warum? Und ich hatte dieses Gummihuhn oder den Sombrero und ich dachte mir, nee, nimm den Sombrero. Der ist ein bisschen dezenter und humaner bei einer Dezen zum Töten. Aber jetzt ist mir aufgefallen, ich gehe morgen in Rente, ich habe nie jemanden getötet. Obwohl, ich könnte ja wirklich jeden, also ich könnte zum Beispiel sie, könnte ich jetzt töten, ohne dass da irgendwie Konsequenzen folgen. Ich habe auch gerade gesehen, auf Ihrem Schein steht, Sehhilfe ist zu tragen, was ich auch gut finde. Ja, aber das war damals. Aber jetzt haben Sie Kontaktlinsen drin oder warum haben Sie keine Brille? Nein, das war damals, ich hatte da Heuschnupfen und bei dem Sehtest hatte ich irgendwie so geschwollene Augen und deswegen konnte ich das. Da steht einfach auf dem, steht Hilfe ist zu tragen drauf.
Es steht drin, aber ich habe das nie gemacht und ich glaube, meine Augen haben sich wieder verbessert in der Zeit.
Aber haben Sie nicht auch dann bei der Prüfung gelernt, dass Sie Gründe brauchen, jemanden umzubringen?
Nein, ich könnte Sie einfach so umbringen und um ganz ehrlich zu sein, je mehr Fragen Sie mir stellen, desto mehr Lust bekomme ich darauf, jetzt einfach mal Gebrauch zu machen, von meiner Lizenz zu töten. Entschuldigen Sie beide, es ist das Ruheabteil. Sehe ich aber nirgendwo. Sieht man nirgendwo. So, wo steht das denn? Wo steht das? Ach da. Ach so, da. Okay, Entschuldigung. Ja, tun wir da, dann sind wir leise. Gut, dann sind wir leise. Dann schraube ich kurz mein... Warum wollen Sie mich jetzt umbringen? Naja, warte mal, Ruheabteil. Er schraubt seinen Schalldämpfer auf seine Pistole. Ja, jetzt viel Spaß in den nächsten fünf Minuten, wo wir euch erklären, was Blodin händisch macht. Und er hält. Der offensichtlich keine Ahnung von Waffen hat, er hat jetzt den Schalldämpfer wieder weggelegt. Ich habe hier eine riesige Kiste mit Dreckusiven da. Das denke ich mir aber auch immer bei uns, wenn wir so, wenn wir voreinander stehen, Improv-Szenen machen, uns der, aber dann auch den deutschen Gedanken frönen, wie wir glauben, Waffen werden benutzt und so. Man merkt immer bei den Amis, dass die alle viel mehr Erfahrung haben. Wenn die dann so Attentatsketche spielen oder was auch immer,
und wie man bei guter Arbeit, wie How Does Anything Work, das fand ich immer sehr interessant. Amis haben einfach mehr, dadurch, dass die, ich weiß nicht, in einer anderen Gesellschaft aufwachsen, wissen die, wie man Waffen bedient. Immer wie jemand die Pistole hält, ist völlig richtig, auch so, oh, er hat noch drei Schüsse im Magazin. Und wir so ... Was ist ein Magazin, was sind Schüsse? Muss nicht jede Kugel einzeln in den Lauf? Mehr als einen Schuss. Ich dachte, das ist so Jack Sparrow-mäßig. Keine Ahnung. Ich hoffe auch, dass ich niemals einen Thriller schreiben muss. Weil die Angst davor, nicht die richtigen Punkte hinzubekommen ... Auch diese bei The Dark Knight am Anfang, oh, er hatte schon noch fünf Schuss, ja, er ist schon durch oder sowas, dann hat er noch einen Schuss, der Bankfee mit dem Joker in der Bank und so, man denkt, gibt es noch Waffen, die überhaupt noch einen begrenzten Schuss, schliess mich nicht nur mit Laser, Laserwaffen, wo es eh egal ist. Das fände ich auch gut, so ein Detektivroman über so einen Detektiv, der keine Ahnung von Waffen hat und immer alles falsch interpretiert. Der Autor sich aber auch nicht sicher ist.
Und dann so, und die Schmauchspuren
schmauchten
an, schmauchten
ihm ins Gesicht.
Der Schmauch stand ihm ins Gesicht geschrieben.
Moment mal, aber der Schmauch ist auf der linken
Seite des Kopfes, aber er war
rechtshändisch. Der Schmauch!
Der Schmauch, Moment mal,
das kann so gar nicht sein. Schmauch. Und dann auch irgendwann driftet der Roman so ab. Schmauch, Schmauch. Wenn man das Wort ziemlich häufig sagt, klingt Schmauch ziemlich bescheuert, findet ihr nicht? Ist Schmauch eine Kombination aus Rauch und Schmutz? Schmauch. Dann dreht man das um, die nächste Seite und steht dann für meine Familie. Und dann war es Oh, die Widmung. Ah, die Widmung habe ich vergessen. Jetzt, Entschuldigung, dann nehme ich mir jetzt mal für meine Familie. Für Isabella. Für Isabella, R-I-P. Und weiter geht's. Schmau, ma-ma-ma-mauch, schmau, schmi, schmau, schmau. Schmulala. Warum geht's nicht Schmach? Warum geht's nicht Sch gibt's der Roman driftet komplett ab einfach. Aber das wäre, glaube ich, mein Thriller-Roman. Wäre die Hälfte Fakten, die nicht richtig sind, und die andere Hälfte YouTube-Videos, wie Waffen benutzt werden, werden zitiert. Weil der Detektiv sich die anguckt. Viele Links, ja. Man muss erst recherchieren. Aber so Widmungen sind auch ein spannendes Thema, oder? Ich denke mir immer so, manchmal lese ich ein Buch, das niemandem gewidmet ist.
Wo ich mir denke so, come on, du kannst noch...
Du hattest keine Freunde, den du nimmst.
Du hattest niemanden, an den du gedacht hast, wo du sagst so, ich, ich, ich, ich schreibe Wörter in ein Buch, ich bin der Beste.
Niemandem gewidmet, niemandem.
Also, wem würdest du, hättest du jemanden in den Hinterhand, wo du weisst, okay,
du, dich merke ich mir vor,
falls ich mal was widmen muss, widme ich es dir.
Ich würde so
mega Gigolo unsympathisch schreiben,
for Anna, I think that was her name.
Oh,
nice.
Das war es von uns,
Frederik und Anna.
For Rachel, but she won't read that. Cause she's dead, I think. Das war's von uns, das war sein Name. Nee, das finde ich ganz gut. Falsch geschrieben. Für Florentin, Fiorentin.
Ich versuche, das wäre ja mein Ziel, dass mir mal was gewidmet wird.
Deswegen immer, wenn jemand ein Buch schreibt, und ich habe gehört, Autorinnen und Autoren sind da sehr sensibel, also bitte passt da auf, wenn jemand sagt, ich schreibe gerade ein Buch, macht nicht den Fehler und fragt ständig, und wie geht's und wie weit bist du, weil das ist ein sensibles Thema, es ist stressig, Deadlines und so so und man will nicht ständig darauf hingewiesen werden ja dass man eigentlich noch sechs Kapitel zu schreiben hat und das noch nicht getan hat also seid da vorsichtig übrigens in dem Sinne lieben gruss an christian hubert check dein neues buch aus ist jetzt erschienen wem ist es gewidmet seiner freundin Isabella deswegen kam ich auch drauf und da habe ich jetzt auch Angst, weil ich jetzt natürlich als Freund
muss ich das natürlich jetzt lesen,
um Feedback zu geben.
Und ich habe so Angst, weil ich bin so ein langsamer,
schlechter Leser, der
erst mal noch sehr viele Bücher von seinem Nachttisch
weglesen muss, dass er,
weil ich kann das auch nicht, ich kann das nicht
dazwischen schieben jetzt, da bin ich zu
OCD dafür. Und deswegen
habe ich jetzt schon Angst vor den vielen Fragen, die kommen werden, jede Woche. Und? Und? Und? Und immer sagen, ich bin ein grauenhafter Leser, ich weiß es nicht. Und hast du Schreibfehler gefunden? Ein. Nee, noch. Ich glaube, einmal bei erschreckt hast du geschrieben, ich habe mich, hätte ich mich erschrocken und das müsste erschreckt heißen. Oder nicht, ich weiß nicht. Ich weiß auch nicht. So was. Das finde ich ja so geil, da hat man dann ja auch einen Lektor oder Lektorin. Aber ist es jetzt so, also angenommen, du hast eine Freundin und du widmest ihr ein Buch, aber du denkst dir, also die hat man ja vielleicht noch länger. Und die Frage ist, welches Buch widmet man ihr? Das jetzt, an dem man gerade schreibt oder das nächste, aber du kannst ja nicht jedes Buch der Freundin widmen. Kann man dann bei der zweiten Auflage, wenn man nicht mehr mit ihr zusammen ist, dann für meine Ex-Freundin schreiben? Ja, genau so was. Oder für diese blöde Olle. Oder sagst du, ah, das Buch, und dann merkst du am Ende des Buchs, ist es so mittel geworden. Viele Handlungsstränge, die ins Nichts führen, viele Figuren, die für einen kurzen Effekt, haha. Aber ich finde gut, dass du es mitten im Buch merkst, dass viele Handlungsstränge ins Nichts führen und du nichts änderst. Nee, irgendwie viele Sachen, wo ich mich in eine Sackgasse manövriert habe, und dann musste ich erklären, warum das im Buch davor so ist. Was ja auch immer super spannend ist, diese Kommunikation zwischen Autor und Leser. Im Buch gibt es ja zum Beispiel bei Harry Potter ganz oft, dass ein Buch veröffentlicht wurde, dann gab es eine Kontroverse oder eine Frage, wie dieses, warum gibt es die Zeitmaschine nicht mehr? In Teil drei gab es die Zeitmaschine. Und dann im übernächsten Buch, wenn sich alle fragen, warum kommt eigentlich in Teil vier die Zeitmaschine nicht mehr vor, dann wird im Buch fünf gibt es so eine Szene, wie und das ist tatsächlich wahr, wie im Ministerium der Magie, aus Versehen die Vitrine kaputt geht, in der alle Zeitmaschinen sind. Und das ist die offizielle Erklärung. Und das ist so geil, weil der Leser denkt sich, das ist doch nicht nötig, aber so dieses, nee, ich muss das jetzt noch gerade biegen, was ich verkorkst habe, und immer so dieses Hin und Her. Deswegen auch das Dumbledore schwul, weil die ganzen Fragen aufkamen, warum Dumbledore nie mit einer Frau in seinem Sekretariat was hatte. Und da gab es dann halt kein weiteres Buch mehr, wo man das dann hätte einbauen können. In einer wahrscheinlich merkwürdigen Szene. In einer fantastischen Szene. Dann bin ich jetzt, ja, und dann muss das so nachgereicht werden. Aber auch dieses, wirklich, ich glaube, da zaubern die irgendwie und dann zaubert einer am anderen vorbei und trifft leider aus Versehen die Vitrine, wo alle diese Zeit zurückdrehen drin sind. Aber das ist ein Zeitsprung, das war davor. Es ist ein Flashback zu einer Szene, die vor. Aber da hätten sie, das beantwortet ja nicht die Frage, warum in Episode 4 das nicht gemacht wurde. Die hätten noch Cedric zurückholen können. Ja, das stimmt schon. Die sind meils gelaufen dafür, diesen Seidenschnabel zurückzuholen. Keiner hat einen Finger gekrümmt, um Cedrics Leben zurückzuholen. Stimmt, ja. Ganz merkwürdig. Das wird dann auch im nächsten Buch wieder geklärt. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob Autoren wie unser lieber Freund Christian Huber auch so arbeiten, dass sie immer wieder Dinge gerade biegen müssen aus dem letzten Buch und immer in so einem Ringen mit den Kritiken hängen oder nicht oder ob die einfach sagen, mir egal. Ich würde ja schon daran scheitern. Wie schreibt man ein Buch in Word? Ich mag Word nicht, der will nicht so viel Zeit verbringen. Textedit, oder? Einfach runterschreiben. Ja, klar. Nein, ein Buch muss man schon auf eine, entweder eine Schreibmaschine oder wirklich auf einem Blattpergament. Ich glaube, ich würde mir wirklich so Hemingway einfach Schreibmaschine und dann wieder. Register. Auflage eins. Aal. Seite fünf, sechzehn, sechsenzwanzig, siebenundzwanzig, achtundzwanzig, neunundervier. Und dann kommt deine Frau, weil du bist in dem verlassenen Hotel, und dann kommt deine Frau und sagt, Schatz, hast du heute schon viel geschafft? Jetzt störe mich nicht! Ich war gerade drin! Nee, ich wollte nur diesen Milchreis vorbeibringen. Hier hast du ein bisschen Milchreis mit Zimt und Zucker. Kann ich mal ein bisschen was lesen? Du schreibst schon tagelang. Ich höre es immer klar. Ach, das ist Müll! Du weißt doch, die ersten drei Kapitel muss ich mir den Schmutz aus der Seele schreiben! Okay, okay. Nimm die Kinder und verlass das Haus! Kinder, okay. Ich will euch den Rest des Monats nicht sehen. Ich brauche meine Zeit für meinen Roman.
Wir sind alleine in diesem ganzen Hotel, wir können nicht einfach weg. Ich kann Danny.
Dann besorg irgendwo Kinder und nimm die mit. Es klingt besser, wenn man sagt, nimm die Kinder und geh.
Das stimmt.
Statt einfach zu sagen, geh. Ich bin Autor.
Ich würde auch lieber sagen, ich würde die Kinder jetzt gerne zu Tante Margaret mitnehmen. Aber wir haben nur Kind Danny. Movie-Referenzen und Buchreferenzen. Und nimm das Gemälde mit! Ich will das nicht mehr sehen, es starrt mich an. Das Gemälde. Das Gemälde. Ich kann nicht schreiben, wenn mich meine Mutter anstarrt.
Deine Mutter.
Das hat sie uns geschenkt, am letzten Geburtstag, bevor sie gestorben ist, und sie wusste genau, was sie tut.
Ihr Fluch wird niemals enden. Sie starrt mich an und ich kann nicht schreiben, wenn sie mich anstarrt.
Nimm die Kinder und das Gemälde.
Ich nehm das Kind und das Gemälde.
So, wo war ich?
Register.
Ich habe eine Schreibmaschine, eine alte, hat mir einen Freund geschenkt.
Die ist sehr cool, damit schreibe ich dann immer Karten, wenn ich Leuten was schenke.
Du bist immer so kurz vorm Hipster, so ein Zentimeter.
Wirklich so, du bist so auf so einer Slackline und ruderst und wenn du einmal nicht ruderst, ah, bist du weg. Slackline ist aber auch eine 2006er Referenz, wir sind jetzt eher Spikeball. Die Schreibmaschine ist eine 860 Referenz. Nee, für uns Hipster, nee, Spikeball wäre es, wobei es nicht Hipster ist, das ist wahrscheinlich einfach the most basic thing. Nee, und da. Wie schreibst du dann süße Einladungskarten. Hey, wir laden euch ein auf eine Soiree. Matinee. T.S., der kleine Baby, Bobby ... Billy. Billy Bob. Billy Bob Thornton, Tietze, ist geboren. Um mal wieder eine weitere Trope zu nehmen, oh, dein bester Freund heißt wie ein Hollywood Hollywood-Star, Billy Bob Thornton-Tietze. Nimm deine Schwester Macaulay Culkin mit! Ich nenne die einfach, Vorname und Nachname ist der Name meines Sohnes. Ist nicht verboten. Billy Bob Thornton-Tietze. Und dann auch kein Bindestrichter zwischen, nein, Billy Bob Thornton ist der Vorname. Und Billy Bob Thornton wurde geboren, 3000 Gramm und Stahlblaue Augen. Da schreibe ich mit der Schreibmaschine und dann verschreibe ich mich natürlich bei Blaue Augen und dann muss ich wegmachen mit der Delete-Taste, die es gibt, die aber nichts macht, als zurückzugehen. Oh, die dir deinen Fehler nochmal zeigt.
Ich will meinen Fehler nochmal sehen.
Die sagt, ich kann nichts dagegen tun.
Ihr wurde gerade mit Tinte auf Papier gedrückt. Was soll ich tun?
Was soll ich in meiner
Machtstehendes tun, um das
wegzumachen? Und auf der Taste sind auch so zwei
Hände, die so hilflos...
Dieses Shrug, dieses I don't know,
I don't know. Wir können zurück zum Problem gehen, wir können dem Gesicht ins Problem ins Auge starren, aber ich weiss nicht, was ich tun soll. Fällt dir denn ein Wort ein, das man jetzt noch vervollständigen könnte? Mir nicht, aber vielleicht ein FFF, vielleicht fällt dir was ein, mir nicht. Und auch das ,, Z ist so ein grosses... Weiß nicht, was willst du von mir? Keine Ahnung. Hä? Hä? Ach so, ähm, nee. Keine Ahnung, aber Schreibmaschine sind schon cool. Ja, du hast schon recht, man fühlt sich ein bisschen hipsterisch und uncool, aber ich finde es schon ganz geil. Ich habe, so ein paar exzentrische Sachen brauchen wir doch, Florentin, dachte ich mir. Und ich dachte, vielleicht ist ein Richtung etwas Exzentrisches bei mir, ach Stefan, der schreibt alle Weihnachtskarten oder so, Geburtstagskarten, nicht einfach nur auf so eine Happy Birthday-Karte, sondern der schreibt dir was auf der Schreibmaschine. Stefan, du hast schon Stefan, der immer Bowlingschuhe trägt, Stefan, der immer einen Lolli in den Mund hat und Stefan, der immer ein Stirnband trägt. Es reicht. Du hast genug exzentrische, gargte Eigenschaften.
Vor allem irgendwann ist es nicht mehr exzentrisch, wenn es einfach zu viel ist, wenn jeder, wenn du, wie bei so einer Papierpuppe, wo du irgendwie auf jedes Körperteil was draufkleben kannst, wo einfach überall was ist, ist zu viel.
Das stimmt nicht. Ich habe die ewig lange Drei-Stunden-Dokumentation von Rammstein gesehen in New York, also in Amerika, heißt die Doku, Rammstein Amerika, und fantastisch. Und die haben auch nicht zu viel. Ja gut, aber das ist auch Rammstein. Also da musst du schon, bei Rammstein haben auch nicht von null auf hundert angefangen. Die haben pretty much von null auf hundert angefangen. Und dann wurde einmal ein Konzert vorverlegt, es war am helllichten Tag, und dann gab es auch irgendwelche Feuerregularien, die nicht gepasst haben, weshalb die am helllichten Tag ohne Pyrotechnik spielen mussten. Und sagen wir so, die Fans waren wenig begeistert, weil wenn das was überbleibt, ist eine normale Band. Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber es ist so lustig, die kann ich jedem empfehlen, weil die ist voller geiler Rockstar-Momente.
Und dann ist irgendwann so der Gitarrist von, also der Sänger von Slipknot in so einer gruseligen, die sind ja gruselige Band, alle sind immer so verkleidet und sehen aus wie der Tod persönlich.
Der Sänger von Slipknot will dann auch nicht gesehen, hat dann so eine Clowns-Maske auf, unglaublich gruselig, und sagt dann so, ja, damals bei einer Show hat unser Gitarrist dann dem, die unterstützt die Band Rammstein, weil deren Gitarrist war irgendwie verletzt oder sowas. Und dann hat unser Gitarrist, und dann gab es so ein Bild von dem, gruseligster Mensch der Welt, auch so The Ring Maze, diese fettige Haare ins Gesicht und so eine toten Maske auf und so. Dann war deren Gitarrist, musste dann bei Rammstein helfen, und dann meinte der Typ so, der Sänger, und der hatte noch nie so viel Schiss in seinem Leben, wie auf dieser Show. Weil der hat sich nicht bewegt, weil ihm wurde so ein X auf den Boden gemalt, und weil er halt überall bei Rammstein-Shows, immer Pyro, überall hinfliegt, Sägen am Start sind. Wie so ein Super-Mario-Level, wo du einfach genau weißt, Sprung, Sprung, ducken, jetzt Sprung. Es ist das unmögliche Super-Mario-Level, deswegen haben die im X auf die Bühne gemacht und der Gitarrist von Slipner hat so Schiss seines Lebens und hat dann so, hat danach so, wahrscheinlich wenn er einen Bambit-Lieder angerufen, so gesagt, können Sie mich abholen? Er hat unter seiner Maske geweint die ganze Zeit, zum Glück hat man es nicht gesehen. Ja, Mark möchte abgeholt werden. Hm, wenig mehr. Immer vorher. Aber das ist so, diese gruligsten Menschen der Welt standen bei Rammstein, er hat sich nicht nicht bewegt, er hat den furchtbarsten Abend seines Lebens. Ja, aber der kriegt dann, also wenn der dann als Gitarrist einspringt, dann kriegt er dann so ein Notenbuch und sitzt dann bei sich zu Hause und sagt, ah, Gis, ach nee, hier ist transponiert. Hier kommt die Bling, ne, Moment mal, das ist ein Cis, hier Ding Ding, Moment, sorry, das ist, ah, der zweite Finger, hier Kring die Kronkring, ne Moment mal, ach Gott, das Lied ist so lang und das wird Coda, genau, das ist die Coda, Coda an, das wird von vorne wiederholt? Und pass unten, dann wechseln wir da in den Sechs-Achtel-Takt, in Takt neunundzwanzig. Da, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, okay.
Hier kommt die Sonne, ein Ze... Und pass, unten wechseln wir da wütende E-Mail. Nice. Wie wir sie letzte Woche geschrieben haben, an die Adresse von Grabova. Betreff die fünf in Klammern zwei Fruchtigen. Ja, ganz richtig. Ein Machtwort würde gesprochen in der Causa die fünf Fruchtigen, denn mein Kritikpunkt war, es sind eigentlich nur zwei Fruchtige. Die Fünffruchtigen, fünf Fruchtwaffeln, Waffeln mit Fruchtfüllung und zwei verschiedene. Ich habe kurz I zoned out a little und es hat sich von außen angehört wie so ein Kinderzungenbrecher. Also die Fünffruchtigen oder so eine Sprachsprecherübung. Nein, die fünf fruchtigen und es ist so, dass es nur zwei verschiedene Sorten sind, was mich zur Weissglut treibt und deswegen habe ich eine gepfefferte Mail geschrieben letzte Woche in der Folge und zwar im Namen der Sünners. Die Familie Sünner mit Billy Bob Thornton Sünner und dann noch so der Abdruck von dem Fuss, von dem Baby in Gau. Und Matthew Perry Jr. Und die kleine Angelina Jolie Söhner. Und ja, ich kann ja jetzt vielleicht mal die Antwort vorlesen, die von Grabova kam. Nein, nein, nein, ich bin jetzt schon, ich habe, mein Puls wird hoch. Und zwar antwortet Grabova gar nicht. Ach, okay. Keine Antwort. Scheiße. Keine Antwort, keine, keine Antwort. Aber das Thema, und da hat uns das Fantastische das Podcast UFO Reddit darauf hingewiesen, ist anscheinend ein grosses Problem mit diesem Fruchtaspekt. Denn es gibt eine Beschwerdeseite bereits für die fünf Fruchtigen, wo ohnehin mal kritisiert wird, dass die nichts Fruchtiges an sich haben. Es gibt in der Zutatenliste weder Fruchtaromen noch sonst irgendwas Fruchtiges, also die fünf Fruchtigen wohl eher nicht. Aber ansonsten ist nichts gekommen. Nichts. Gar nichts. Gar nichts.
Gar nichts.
Es ist schon ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Hier gibt es auch im Reddit gesehen die Helgoländer Waffeln, die ein Lars Kritze-ähnliches Wesen drauf haben.
Aber die sind völlig stimmig. Die Helgoländer Waffeln sind drei Stück, drei Waffeln, auch wieder weiss und rot, diesmal aber im Big Mac-Format, also Waffel, Weiss, Waffel, Pink, Waffel und vorne und hinten in Kuvertüre getunkt und die heißen Helgoländer Waffeln und da ist auf dem Bild ein Fischer Seemann zu sehen, fantastisch, passt zu Helgoländer. Auf der neuen Version dann eine Waffe. Ich habe ein Problem damit, wenn das Produkt ein Maskottchen hat, was ebenfalls das Produkt ist.
Ja.
Weil man isst dann das Maskottchen.
Genau. Keine Chance. Wie zum Beispiel Ü-Ei oder so, Maskottchen isst ein Überraschungsei mit Arm und Bein. Ja. Ich sage so, ja, ich schneide dich auf. Oder Kinderriegel. Ja. Oder, aber hier bei den Helgoländer Waffeln ist halt auch eine Helgoländer Waffel dann Kapitän. Und man denkt, man hat dieses schöne, fröhliche Comicbuchlächeln in seinem Gesicht und man denkt, du wirst sterben. Ich werde dir den Kopf abbeissen, von dem ich bis gerade nicht mehr wusste, dass es überhaupt ein Kopf ist. Und deswegen mag ich diese Lars-Kritze-Idee. Ich glaube, ich habe mal ein Bild auch gesehen, wo das Maskottchen, das das Produkt war, die Produkte selbst wiederum isst. Also das ist auch wirklich dann, wo man sich denkt, was genau passiert hier, wie soll man das einem Kind erklären, dass man das gerade isst oder was das gerade isst, oder ob es halt einfach nach dessen Vorbild gemacht wurde in klein, schwer zu sagen. Und dann gab es einen Aufschrei, den ich auch im Reddit gelesen habe, von Maoam, denn das neue Maoam-Produktdesign ist sehr zotig. Du hast nämlich dieses grüne Männchen. Es gibt dieses grüne Männchen. Ja, das habe ich mir auch schon mal gedacht. Und das grüne Männchen ist wie so ein Mars, so eine Marsbohne, marsiges Marsianerbohne. Marsbohne? Wie so ein Mars. So ein ausserirdischer, so ein grüner Alien. Und ja, so bohnenförmig. Und dieses Wesen ist zu sehen in diversen sexuellen Praktiken mit Früchten, den jeweiligen Früchten der Geschmacksrichtung. Und da gab es so einen Aufschrei, der von einem katholischen Gymnasium ausging. Die Geschichte war, dass katholische SchülerInnen dann eine Beschwerdemail geschickt haben, aber im Scherz, nur im Scherz, wo man auch sagen muss, liebes katholische Gymnasium, Beschwerdemails im Scherz funktionieren nicht, außer mit einem grossen Zinkersmiley davor oder dahinter. Ihr habt keine mehrtausendjährige Geschichte des Humors hinter euch stehen, also da wäre ich vorsichtig. Und auch wahrscheinlich gross oben so ein Kreuz da drüber oder so. Ich weiß nicht, wie die Briefform ist eines katholischen Gymnasiums. Von daher wäre ich da vorsichtig mit lustigen Beschwerdemails. Je nachdem, wie dem auch sagt, es wurde gelesen von Mauam, da wurde sich darüber amüsiert, das Produktdesign ist weiterhin das gleiche. Es gab danach einen grossen Aufschrei. Viele sind auf den Zug aufgesprungen, auf diesen Spaßzug. Aber gab es denn eine Erklärung von Mauerm, was das dann sein soll? Was diese Bohne denn eigentlich macht? Weil, also ich dachte, das wäre mehr oder weniger so gedacht, weil die Idee ist halt, diese Mauermfigur hat, ja, Geschlechtsverkehr mit einer Frucht und dadurch entsteht das Fruchtmauerm. Das ist so ein Lüstling. Das ist wirklich ein Lüstling. Diese grüne Bohne. Vor allem, er geht halt auch fremd. So, er ist halt null treu. Wissen wir nicht. An einem Tag die Zitrone, am nächsten Tag die Orange. Wissen die voneinander? Ich glaube schon. Ist das eine offene Beziehung? Ist das Polyamorie? Weiss die Zitrone von der Orange? Oder gibt es da irgendwie Terminplan, Strategien? Sex Positivity. Er ist sowohl der aktive Partner als auch der passive Partner. Er ist wirklich, also dieses grüne Lustling ist wirklich fantastisch. Und für mich jetzt mein neuer Platz eins bei den Süßigkeiten. Maskottchen, ja. Bei dem Maskottchen, der grüne Lüstling. Der auch offiziell bei Mauam so genannt wird. Ja, der ist unser kleiner Lüstling. Ja, warum denn nicht? Mauam. Auf jedem Mauam ist der drauf, der grüne, die grüne Bohne. Weiß man auch nicht warum, ne? Also woher kommt denn die grüne Bohne? Aber auch null Charakterdesign-Kreativität, einfach ein grüner Blob mit Händen, mit Armen und Füssen.
So ein Marsmännchen.
Das ist furchtbar.
Warum ist das was Göttchen von Marsriegel, nicht ein Marsmännchen?
Na, das ist so. Oder halt der Gott, der Kriegsgott.
Aber das kann es halt auch nicht machen, ist halt ein bisschen naheliegend.
Die göttlichen Riegel? Das ist halt zu schwierig.
Ja.
Wäre das was für uns, die göttlichen Riegel?
Ja, ja, Venusriegel, Thorriegel, also dann alle Götter oder innerhalb von einer Mythologie? Von unserem Planeten. Da ist es natürlich schwierig. Ich glaube, da kommt man manchmal in Schwierigkeiten, wenn du dann irgendwie Ganesha den Rüssel abbeisst oder so. Dann hast du eine Schwierigkeit, oder Vishnu, dann hast du ein Problem. Wenn man alle Götter macht? Ja, aber welcher ist der leckerste? Wer kriegt Zitrone?
Das ist natürlich das Problem. Und wer ist
irgendwie so ein, welcher Gott bleibt
dann im großen Celebrations-Topf
als letzter immer zurück? Und die
Gläubigen beschweren sich. Warum
bleibt unser Gott immer zurück am Schluss?
Naja, der Buddhisten, das hat
doch damit nichts zu tun. Das ist halt
nun mal krokant, das mögen nicht so viele Leute.
Warum haben wir krokant bekommen? Wenn die Christen am Karamell bekommen, das ergibt so halbwegs Sinn. Die heilige Maria-Mürre-Riegel. Ich meine, das ergibt halbwegs Sinn, ja, Maria hat Mürre geliebt. Und schmeckt fantastisch. Ehrlich gesagt, es schmeckt kreistlich. Wir dachten, das wäre zurückgeblieben dann immer in den Kartons. Wir wollten ja nicht ahnen, dass Mürre der neueste heiße Scheiße ist. Die Leute lieben den Mürre-Geschmack. Glaubst du, dass Mürre mal so ein, was schon wieder über Mürre reden ist, eh, brauchen wir nicht drüber reden, aber irgendwann so ein Revival wie Avocado, was irgendwann so da war? Ich glaube ja, ich glaube ganz klar ja. Ich glaube, das kommt mal wieder auf und das ist wahrscheinlich so ein Ding, das so ähnlich wie Matcha oder so beginnt irgendwie in so Barista, Hipster-Barista-Läden, wo man das dann mal so macht. Wo ich mit meiner Schreibmaschine immer sitze. Genau, und da gibt es dann irgendwie, willst du noch Mürre auf deinen Latte? Und du so, ja, natürlich, klar, wir haben gerade frisch Mürre reinbekommen und dann trinkst du das und dann irgendwann gibt es den riesen Mürre-Hype. Und Weihrauch vielleicht auch in so Shisha-Bars? Auf jeden Fall, ich glaube eh, dass noch mal ein Religions-Revival kommt. Ganz gross. Ich glaube nicht daran. Ich glaube, es war es jetzt.
Ja, aber ich glaube, alles kommt noch mal irgendwann zurück. Wir haben jetzt, glaube ich, so noch ein paar hundert Jahre Säkularisation und dann geht es noch mal richtig hoch. Super. Kenne ich das Wort. Bin ich stolz auf mich. Ich dachte eigentlich, dass ich nach diesem fünf fruchtigen Dingen endlich mal eine Woche Ruhe hätte. Dass ich endlich mal so meinen Schreibtisch abgearbeitet habe, alle Probleme weg, stellt sich raus, das nächste Problem flattert direkt rein, in Briefform. Und die schlimmsten Probleme erscheinen in Briefform. Und ich habe eine Briefform bekommen, und zwar eine saftige Stromnachzahlung. Aha. Ich muss richtig viel Geld nachzahlen. Und wie ich dich kenne, ich dachte, ich hätte kurz die Hoffnung, dass es ein katholisches Gymnasium ist, was dir geschrieben hat. Nein. Okay, die Stromnachzahlung. Aber wie ich dich kenne, hast du diesen Brief ja wahrscheinlich mehrere Monate lang nicht geöffnet. Zum Glück ging der Brief nicht an mich, sondern an einen verantwortungsvolleren Menschen, nämlich meinen ehemaligen Mitbewohner Lars Paulsen. Was ist die Paulsen? der das auch zahlen musste, diese saftige Nachzahlung, und zu Recht sich beschwert hat, weil es zu einer riesigen Nachzahlung kam, und zwar Lächerlich. Ich bin da noch dran. Nachzahlung 800 Euro. Für einen Zeitraum von drei Monaten. Hahaha! das sind Messfehler. So, und jetzt wird das hier aufgedröselt, nämlich die Messstände wurden abgelesen. Und von dem Betrag, also in Kilowattstunden, der mir zusätzlich in Rechnung gestellt wird, ist mehr als die Hälfte in 25 Tagen passiert. In 25 Tagen habe ich Strom im Wert von bestimmt 500 Euro verbraucht, mehr als eigentlich meine Rechnung ist. War das nicht auch die Zeit, wo du irgendwann mal so Strommessgeräte an deinen Kühlschrank geheftet hast, um herauszufinden, wie der Fälle verbraucht, ohne zu wissen, dass nebenan irgendein Gerät steht, was viel schlimmer ist. So, und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, was ist in diesen 25 Tagen passiert? Ja, kannst du diesen Zeitraum, can you narrow it down? Wie ist es überhaupt möglich? Fun Fact, es handelt sich um die Hamburger Wohnung, in der ich nur zwei Tage die Woche bin. Okay. Das heißt, von diesen
25 Tagen war ich
vielleicht sechs Tage überhaupt
anwesend. Das heißt, ich habe
in dieser Zeit es geschafft,
pro Tag ungefähr 100 Euro
Strom zu verbrauchen. Und ich habe
nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung,
was passiert ist. Kannst du denn
den Foto-Roll durchgehen, zum Beispiel, um
herauszufinden, wo du in diesen Tagen warst? So, genau das habe ich gemacht. Nice. Und ich habe ein Foto gefunden. Oh mein Gott, ich glaube, ich glaube, ich rutsche. Und zwar kam ich eines Tages in Hamburg an, gehe in meine Wohnung, gehe in die Küche und sehe, bei meinem Kühlschrank steht das Gefrierfach offen.
Aha.
Und natürlich der erste Instinkt, oh nein, da wurde eingebrochen, jemand hat meine Erbsen geklaut.
Weil du kennst ja vielleicht diesen Moment manchmal, man kommt nach Hause und hat das Gefühl, hier wurde eingebrochen.
Und die Erbsen sind weg, ja.
Und was ist das erste, woran du denkst?
Weil ich habe in meiner Wohnung nahezu nichts Wertvolles.
Das Wertvollste, was ich wahrscheinlich habe, ist mein Laptop, den nehme ich immer mit überall hin, der bleibt da nicht. Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, du denkst, weil ich habe in meiner Wohnung nahezu nichts Wertvolles. Das Wertvollste, was ich wahrscheinlich habe, ist mein Laptop, den nehme ich immer mit überall hin, der bleibt da nicht. Das kann aber, so jetzt habe ich überlegt, was ist hier passiert. Ich wurde nicht ausgeraumt. Und jetzt schaue ich in dieses Eisfach rein und sehe eine geplatzte Dose Spezi. Anscheinend hat die Dose Spezi die Tür aufgestossen. Anscheinend hatte ich eine Dosespezi im Gefrierfach, hatte vor, sie zu trinken, habe sie vergessen. Und diese Dose war ein fantastischer Anblick, weil vorn und hinten komplett rausgewölbt. Und anscheinend ist die irgendwann in meiner Abwesenheit, ist die Dosespezi explodiert und hat das Gefrierfach aufgeschossen, was dann tagelang offen stand. Ja. Und das ist das Einzige, was ich mir erklären kann, wo ich mir aber auch da dachte, also selbst das kostet so viel Geld. Aber es ist sehr interessant, dass du recherchierst, was kann es gewesen sein und genau in diesem Zeitraum das Bild findest. Es ist des Zufalls zu viel. Ich dachte mir vor allem, diese fucking Dose hat mich 500 Euro gekostet. Das war ein folgenschwerer Fehler. War eine fucking Prankdose. Also jetzt erstmal an alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, falls ihr Getränke im Eisfach noch mal kühlen wollt, legt sie so hin. Also gerade, ich glaube, Flaschen brechen halt einfach und dann ist egal. Aber Dosen, die wölben sich ja erstmal so auf und dann muss es einen lauten Knall gegeben haben. Die Tür fliegt auf und ich bin noch Tage in Köln woanders, während einfach rund um die Uhr dieses Eisfach kühlt, kühlt, kühlt, kühlt, kühlt. Es kann schon teuer werden, glaube ich, so ein kühleses Eisfach. Aber so teuer weiß ich nicht. Du kennst mich? Ich werde mich dahinter klemmen. Weil ich werde mir den Abzähler angucken, ob das stimmt. Ich werde da anrufen und sagen, was zur Hölle war da los. Und ich habe schon mal auf so ein paar Rechenseiten geguckt, das kommt nicht hin. Weil, also, ich würde immer sagen, da gab es offensichtlich einen Messfehler. So würde ich immer in diese Gespräche. Würde ich auch sagen. Aber es ist schon merkwürdig, dass du genau in diesem Zeitraum auf dieses Bild stößt. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie dein, ob das jetzt, weil du hast, wer Florian kennt, weiss, du steckst häufig Getränke in Gefrier. Ja, aber ich vergesse ihn. Und wer dich auch kennt, weiss, dass du ihn in der Regel auch vergisst eigentlich. Manchmal. So, und deswegen ist es ein ongoing phenomenon. Ja. Deswegen bin ich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig überrascht, dass du genau in diesem Zeitraum zufällig auch ein Bild findest davon. Ja, ich habe da ein Foto gemacht, weil ich das so witzig fand, dass ich mir selber einfach, dass ich diese Scheissdose, also wenn das wirklich stimmt, dass diese Scheissdose mir 500 Euro kostet, dann beschwer ich mich. Vor allem kann man denn nicht irgendwo sagen, hey sorry, also zum Beispiel jetzt, wenn du dir so ein Carsharing-Auto mietest und du vergisst es abzusperren über Tage, ist mir auch schon mal passiert, hat dann irgendwie 900 Euro gekostet, dann ruft man da an und sagt, sorry, ihr seht ja, das stand tagelang nur rum, das wurde nicht gefahren, dann sagen die, okay, passt, cool, buchen die 900 Euro zurück. Gibt es sowas auch bei Strom, dass man sagt, hey, sorry Leute, mir ist eine Dose explodiert, das war richtig dumm und die sagen, ja klar, passiert, kein Problem, hier hast du dein Geld wieder, gibt es sowas? Oder sagen die, naja, der Strom ist jetzt weg. Ja. Das geht jetzt nicht. Aber ich finde es auch gut, das bin ich gerade bei Finanzfrage.net, ich glaube, es ist eine Schwesterseite von gutefrage.net, Gefriertruhr drei Ertrage offen gelassen, Stromrechnung in Capitals? Haben ein dringendes Anliegen. Und dann passiert das Internet passiert. Es wird nicht auf die Frage geantwortet, es wird auf andere Fragen geantwortet, die gar nicht gestellt wurden. Und dann gibt es eine große Diskussion über das Gendern, wie dem auch sei. Aber vor sechs Jahren immerhin. Naja, da ist viel Fragepunkt nett, aber echt weit. Muss man auch mal sagen. Am Puls der Zeit. Man kann heute vieles versichern. Dazu gehört eine Versicherung für eigenes Fehlverhalten. Die finde ich für dich nicht so schlecht. Würde ich auch mittragen als dein Co-Partner. Moment, das ist eine Versicherung gegen Dummheit? Naja, nennen wir es eigenes Fehlverhalten. Nennen wir es for legal reasons eigenes Fehlverhalten. Aber ich habe mich ja nicht falsch verhalten. Die Dose hat sich falsch verhalten.
Die Dose ist ausser Rand und Band explodiert und ich habe eigentlich nichts falsch gemacht.
Nein, liebe Jury, die Dose hat sich entsprechend der physikalischen Gesetze verhalten.
Nein, das können Sie mir nicht beweisen.
Doch.
Ich zeige Ihnen jetzt, was passiert, wenn ich jetzt diese Dose hier in das Eisfach packe.
Achtung, jetzt mache ich es so.
Ja, gar nichts passiert. Warten Sie ab. Richter fängt an, mit seinem Hammer zu spielen. Und so Doodles zu malen auf seinem Block. Haben Richter Blöcke? Schreiben die mit? Was machen die Richter? Schreiben sich Lyrics mit.
Haben die so einen Block vor sich, wo sie so rumdudeln und so Staatsanwalt malen? Also, klar, ich bin jetzt hier Richter, aber ich arbeite ja eigentlich gerade an meiner Hip-Hop-Karriere. Also ich will ja eigentlich Rapper werden. Ich gebe Ihnen Beat, ich gebe Ihnen Beat, Judge. Okay, schauen Sie einfach mal, ich habe ein bisschen was aufgeschrieben. Your Honor, Your Honor. Okay. Ich sitze im Gerichtssaal und spreche das Recht. Ich halte mich dabei an Gesetze. Entschuldigung. Ich mache das nicht so häufig. Okay, ich auch nicht. Sorry, ich bin ein bisschen nervös. Aber wir müssen eh gerade warten. Sorry, es ist eh gerade... Okay. Your Honor. Alles klar. Das ist ein guter Name. Your Honor. Your Honor. Okay, alles klar. Your Honor. okay. Paragraph 85, ihr seid echt nicht cool, ich bin der Beste hier im Gerichtssaal. Ich schaue mir die Fakten an und dann entscheide ich, die Geschworenen können mich mal. Nein! Ja, ich weiß nicht, irgendwie hat es noch nicht den Menschen. Es reimt sich noch nicht. Es reimt sich halt leider noch gar nicht. So, wie sieht es jetzt aus? Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa der Wohnung des Nachbarn, kann man da dann nicht mal reingehen. Und jetzt habe ich mir nämlich den nächsten Verdächtigen. Und zwar, meine zweite Theorie ist Stromdiebstahl. Weil, wenn ich als Nachbar irgendwann merke, mein Nachbar ist vier, fünf Tage die Woche nicht da, immer, dann könnte ich mir, also jetzt Unterstellung, Achtung, Unterstellung ab jetzt, dann kenne ich mir, ich schmeisse da mal irgendwie ein Kabel durchs Fenster. Ja, Moment, alles. Du unterstellst nämlich nicht nur ein Kabel, du unterstellst ja Trespassing auch. Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie man das genau macht. Er muss ja bei dir reinlaufen, dein Nachbar. Und muss er bei dir einbrechen und dann bei dir eine Steckdose stecken. Kann man nicht von der Leitung irgendwie was abzwacken oder so? Oder er muss die Wand aufbrechen und deine Kabel anbohren oder so. Aber kann man nicht sich in den Keller schleichen und da was abzwacken? Meine Theorie ist Elektroauto. Jemand aus dem Haus hat sich ein Elektrofahrzeug gekauft, hat sich dann überlegt, okay, cool, lass mir eine Leitung irgendwie verlegen, war dann am Sicherungskasten und hat das Falsche genommen. Hat die Falsche, hatitung genommen. Und das hat nach 25 Tagen gemerkt. Das ist meine Theorie. Was sagt denn jetzt Finanzfrage? Wie viel kostet das denn pro Tag? Weil das Problem ist, es ist halt so ein Kühlschrank, wo oben das Gefrierfach ist. Das heißt, kalte Luft geht nach unten, wissen wir ja. Das heißt, die kalte Luft fließt da konstant raus, anders als jetzt so eine Truhe, die nach oben offen ist, wo man ja vielleicht das konserviert, weil das so ein bisschen in sich bleibt, sondern es fließt halt ständig raus, die kalte Luft.
Also der Klaus schreibt, noch mal kurz, maximale Leistungsaufnahme in Watt 72 Stunden, Watt mal 72 Stunden mal 30 Cent sind gleich die Stromkosten.
Also dann Leistungsaufnahme in Watt. Für dieses Gerät musst du herausfinden, mal die Anzahl der Tage mal 30 Stromkosten. Was kostet das ungefähr? Wenn die maximale Leistungsaufnahme mit 200 Watt beträgt, wären das 4,32 Euro Stromkosten. Pro Tag oder Stunde? Für 72 Stunden. Für 72 Stunden? Das kommt doch im Leben nicht hin. Während während es 4,32 Mitglieder der Partei, die Grünen müssen fortan genderneutral sagen, ich habe das gefriert, offen gelassen. Okay, lass uns da jetzt an der Stelle kurz aushacken. Also 4 Euro für drei Tage. Ich hasse das Internet. Es ist so, ich erinnere mich da an Aquariumzeit, wo ich aber nur wissen wollte, wie viele Guppis ich zu meinen Neonfischen packen kann und dann das passiert ist. Es ist nämlich immer, wenn du eine Frage hast im Forum, wirst du immer auch des Tiermordes bezichtigt, du kannst diese Fische nicht bedienen, also du wirst immer beleidigt, es ist insane, von wie vielen Ecken man sich Angreifer macht, wenn man so eine harmlose Frage ins Internet postet. Es geht nicht. Und deswegen glaube ich als Menschheit, wir kommen nicht mehr weiter. Ich frage mich halt auch, was sind das für Leute, die auf Finanzfrage.net aktiv sind, also die ja nicht, die ja wahrscheinlich sich dann jede Frage durchlesen, die da gepostet wird, unabhängig von ihrer eigenen Kompetenz und dann halt einfach zu jedem was schreiben wollen oder eine Meinung haben zu allem, egal ob sie gerade was zum Thema zu sagen haben oder nicht. Aber selbst dann kommt es doch nicht im Leben hin mit dem viel Geld. Nein, nein, nein, 72 Stunden sind gerade 4,32 Euro. Das ist viel weniger, als ich auch dachte. Also ich hätte auch gedacht, da kommt es hin, check das mal aus, ich würde da mal ein bisschen für Furore sorgen in deinem Exhaus. Ich glaube, es ist gar nicht...
Ehemaliges Haus, richtig?
Da bist du nicht mehr.
Doch, doch, da bin ich schon noch.
Ah, da bist du noch.
In Hamburg.
Ich glaube, es ist gar nicht möglich, so viel Strom zu verbrauchen, weil ich habe einen Kühlschrank, eine Waschmaschine und Licht.
Und halt, ich lade mein Handy auf.
Gut, Licht war wahrscheinlich gleißend an, Waschmaschine...
Auch nicht wirklich.
...offen.
Ich meine, die Wohnung hat extrem viele Steckdosen. Ich habe in einem Raum 20 Steckdosen. Ich weiß nicht genau, welcher Knotenpunkt das ist. Das sagt aber doch aus, dass davor jemand war, der da wahrscheinlich so eine Serverfarm hatte oder sowas. Und du meinst, der beim Bau des Hauses gesagt hat, ich brauche 20 Steckdosen? Irgendwer hat da immer gesagt, ich brauche jetzt 20 Steckdosen, weil ich baue mir noch 19 Steckdosen hier in diesem Raum. Und deswegen, vielleicht sind die Leitungen angeknackst, weil die gewohnt sind, dass da eigentlich jemand wohnt, der eine Renderfarm betreibt. Theorie Nummer zwei. Aber also ich werde da, sobald wir hier nach Hause gekommen sind, werde ich da anrufen und ich werde wirklich da Ramba Zamba machen. Mach da mal richtig Rambazamba. Ich mache da wirklich Rambazamba, weil die werden ja auch merken, also so eine Stromfirma weiß ja, was ein Haushalt so im Monat verbraucht. Und wenn da jetzt plötzlich einer so 60 Euro, 60 Euro, 60 Euro, 500 Euro, 60, dann werden die auch checken, irgendwas stimmt hier nicht. Übrigens, wie bei mir Rambazamba machen klingt immer, ist so, ich bin richtig sauer, flippe auch, bin auch dann laut zu Hause und so. Und dann macht's Tut, Tut und dann sag ich, ja hi, der Stefan Tietze, ja hallo, Stefan Tietze, ja genau, nee, ich wollte nur mal fragen, wegen dieser Stromkrecht. Nee, das wurde von uns so abgezählt und das haben wir gemacht und das ist so. Alles klar, gut, danke schön, schönen Tag noch.
Exakt so wird das auch ablaufen. Aber welche Rolle spielt Paulana in der ganzen Sache?
Es war ein Paulaner Spezi. Kann ich jetzt Paulana ...
Was, was, was, was, was?
Die Spezi, die Dose Spezi, kann ich das denen nicht in Rechnung stellen?
Der hat ja einen Schlaganfall.
Kann ich da nicht jetzt zumindest mal ...
Kann ich da zumindest mal nicht, dass wir uns den Betrag teilen?
Wir?
Ja, ja, wir. Ich jetzt, von Paulana Weissbier. Sorry, ich bin betrunken. Ich bin so raus schon. Dass ich da zumindest, dass sie mal ein Hunni drauflegen. Auf deren Dosen steht nicht, Vorsicht, legen sie die nicht im 90-Grad-Winkel zur Tür des Eisfachs, weil sonst sprengt unser Produkt ihren Geldbeutel auf. Ich möchte diesen Teppich nicht kaufen. So, wenn das jetzt verstehst, diese... Wenn ich Paulaner wäre, würde ich das sagen und dann auflegen. Und dann... Ich verstehe's leider nicht. Komm's dir grob bekannt vor. Habe ich das jetzt so ... Ich möchte diesen Teppich nicht ... Kauf ... Teppich. Ja, das ist die Paulana-Werbung, die alte Paulana-Werbung. Ach Gott. Und dann bringt sie Paulane. Ach so, ja, sie weiß schon, was ... Hochgradig, falsch. Alles daran ist falsch. Wow, ey, das ist echt ... Also da hast du mich jetzt zum wunden Punkt erwischt, dass ich eine Paulane-Anspülung nicht verstehe, wo ich ja riesen Fan bin. Wo du ja Bier auch liebst. Weil ich meine ganze Jugend im Biergarten verbracht habe. Aber ja, also ich werde die nächste Woche, und ich dachte eigentlich, ich hätte die Woche mal frei. Es ist dieses die für ein fruchtigen Thema vom Tisch. Ja. Aber nein, ich habe nicht frei, ich muss mich wieder um irgendeinen Schwachsinn kümmern. Ja, übrigens vielen Dank an die Leute, die sich um den Schwachsinn von vor zwei Wochen gekümmert haben und den Batman-Werker gefunden haben. Es gab viele Leute mit dem Backbagger. Ey, wirklich, es lohnt sich immer mehr, auf Reddit das Podcast UFO zu abonnieren. Da werden viele coole Sachen gepostet. Weil der ist geil, der sagt literally, Gotham City ist in Not, ruft Batman. Warte mal, für alle, die zu faul sind, auf Reddit zu schauen, können wir das gerne noch mal einspielen. Weil es ist großartig, vielen, vielen Dank an Lenz Schifter, der hat diesen Wecker tatsächlich, besitzt ihn. Und dieser Wecker, von dem wir gesprochen haben, den wir eingebaut haben in unseren guter Arbeit Original Sketch mit der Präsidentschaftswahl, der klingt so. Boston City ist in Not, so Batman. Batman. Das ist fantastisch. Was aber auch zeigt, dass ich damals erst eingesprochen habe für unseren weirden Sketch, wo der drin gelandet ist, naja, wie dem auch sei, die amerikanische Version sagt Gotham City needs you, wake up, Batman.
Was natürlich, und jetzt habe ich diesen Wecker zum ersten Mal verstanden, der spielt Du bist Batman, der wirft dann auch mit dieses Ding an die Wand, mit dieser kleinen Lampe, die dabei ist und sagt, Gotham City needs you, wake up Batman und du wachst auf und bist froh, dass du Gotham City helfen kannst, wohingegen die deutsche Version sagt, Gotham City ist in Not, ruft Batman, als ob du und wirft dich in diese uncoole Statistenrolle. Du musst jetzt Batman rufen. Aber wahrscheinlich nicht mal Commissioner Gordon, der hat es ja nicht selber gemacht. Das heißt, du bist dann, du spielst in den deutschen, in der deutschen Lore, bist du dann plötzlich einfach so ein Depot, der dann da irgendwie Batman rufen muss. Mann, das sind so falsch übersetzen, ey. Wach auf Batman, wach auf Batman. Du musst auch nicht mal Lippensynchron sein oder so. Das ist nicht, du musst es einfach nur übersetzen. Und derjenige, der es gepostet hat, hat auch noch mal betont, dass dieses kurze Übersteuern nicht von seinem Mikrofon kommt, sondern tatsächlich der Ton kurz übersteuert. Also super schlechte Qualität. Wir hören es noch mal rein. Gotham City ist in Not. Ruf Batman. Absolut absurd. Wahnsinn. Aber es freut uns sehr, dass wir dieses Mysterium jetzt nach all der Zeit mal lösen konnten. Und ich glaube, es ist von Bastian Pastewka, der hat mich da mal irgendwann draufgebracht. Das kann gut sein. An der Stelle auch liebe Grüße an Bastian Pastewka. Und ja, ansonsten, ich hoffe, dass wir nächste Woche ein paar Antworten kriegen. Einmal auf das Dosen-Mysterium und einmal natürlich die fünf Fruchtigen. Man schweigt sich da gerade noch aus, aber wir werden nach den Antworten jagen. Ansonsten wünschen wir euch eine schöne Woche.
Macht's gut, kommt gut durch. Genießt die Sonne. Und wir sehen uns nächste Woche live in Hamburg.
Wir freuen uns schon sehr. Macht's gut, ciao.
Macht's gut, ciao.